dr matheson you can't imagine how
pleased i am to see you uh-huh uh this
is dr matheson actually that's dr
buckley oh i'm sorry nice to meet you
there are two kinds of people out there
with a special gift
the ones who really think they have some
kind of power
and the other guys
who think we can't figure them out no
leo correct your position to your right
richard vargas i'm calling richard
vargas in the name of god
they're both wrong
so have you been working for matheson
long or are you a psychologist too or a
magician
actually i'm a physicist so why do you
do this do what
investigate fake paranormal stuff simon
silver perhaps the most celebrated
psychic of all time will visit us here
in just under three weeks there will be
a mad rush for tickets
are there no real challenges left out
there silver is a real challenge
silver's already been investigated yeah
like 30 years ago we should investigate
him now
forget about silverton there's certain
things it's better not to know
he's dangerous
stay away from
there's only one way
of gaining access to the truth
what's going on
you challenging me are you questioning
my power
silver